I have to punish this a little,
isn't it?  Since then, why am I the one who's been stealing rewards?
You're the one who's hiding your true identity and pretending to be a hero of justice.
Do you know what happened to that country after the big push?
[MUSIC]
That's all
the villagers.
But that was only for a short while.This
time, the resistance people started
raising taxes.I don't know why it's difficult,
but it seems that protecting the country costs money.
What you did was just a change of mind It didn't solve anything
Please don't change the problem
Now we're impersonating How do I explain
?  If it's there, it's good
to talk about why.
Why
do you think you died because of
you?
don't wake up eh